[Musique]
créée en 2018 est basée à montigny le
bretonneux l'accord a développé un
concept de sûreté mobile et
transportable de contrôle d'accès du
public sur des grands événements
découverte du prototype du lapd ou avec
le président cofondateur et jan krauze à
jemappes aliens crouzade j'ai 44 ans je
suis le co fondateur et président depuis
le mois de juin de la société l'accord
[Musique]
nous développons des concepts de
contrôle d'accès mobile et transportable
pour le grand public et donc tout ce qui
touche aux événements culturels sportifs
mais aussi aux sites sensibles
[Musique]
je vais mais qui paie avec ce que l'on
peut avoir de façon très naturelle
dessus sur sade dans notre quotidien
d'un téléphone d'un portefeuille d'une
clé tout est réglé de façon à pouvoir
faire en sorte de fluidifier les flux
donc voilà qu'on ne vous le voyez avec
tout ce que j'ai dans les poches
téléphone stylo clé badge la machine n'a
pas n'a pas sonné
[Musique]
maintenant l'idée c'est de se dire le
tient
je rajoute en un couteau et l'a du coup
je deviens dangereux et je vais le
mettre
pourquoi pas d'art dans la chaussette
de la chaussette lors d'une d'un
contrôle de sac l'agent de sécurité ne
le verra absolument pas et lors d'une
palpation sauf si elle est poussée c'est
pareil c'est compliqué à venir c'est un
peu la passion jusqu'à emballé cheville
donc on va voir
où
dont là vous l'avez entendu on a une
détection on peut aller voir peut-être
sur la table est ici où se situe la
détection
la machine a bien analysé la personne
mais aussi l'endroit exact où se situe
l'objet interdite
[Musique]
on
va essayer maintenant avec une sacoche
oui j'ai déjà dû du matériel personnel
là ma sacoche ou des papiers encore
quelques petits
quelques petits câbles de batterie
franchement
on va prendre un couteau un gros couteau
et puis je voulais gagner ici à travers
mes documents
[Musique]
je veux une alarme qui vraisemblablement
m'indiquer un problème au niveau de ma
s'accroche voilà c'est indiquer ici donc
là il va y avoir derrière un agent de
sécurité qui va venir lever le doute
[Musique]
on va faire une démonstration de
simulation avec de l'explosif
si villa explosif qui correspond à peu
près à 1 kg 5 julien va s'équiper de
façon à vous démontrer
que la machine analyse la chose
différemment
qu'une détection couteau ou arme à feu
on voit bien que le code couleur a
changé on est sur du rouge et on voit
exactement la zone qui est qui va être
pour le coup plus que sensible et où
l'agent de sécurité va venir
immédiatement mauvais de doute
[Musique]